hello and welcome to Z on playing URI
okay some Russell emo people adopted a
five a lot nowadays after Magnus played
in the World Championships but you're
also getting this line quite frequently
yeah this is a line that head on the
board quite a lot and I think white
enjoys some small but comfortable
advantage I came to quite remember how
this works you know think doubling
[Music]
do you connect five here or how does
that work again is easy five hanging
let's let's start with this this this
first
mitem Lego Knight g5 is going to play
Knight deform yeah anyway I'm taking too
long him
he just wants him centralized it seems
it's not a not a bad thing or bad idea
okay let's take this and try to be
annoying here okay so I just want to go
to age 4 inmate him which is stopped
no it's very relaxed about all this
isn't that dangerous somehow
okay I'm not mating immediately but
Bishop to Bishop hmm okay it's not a
real threat now that I think of it it's
not clear that I'm threatening directly
it looks dangerous but it might not be
an immediate an immediate threat so
let's say
[Music]
yeah it's not I'm not threatening all
that much
I still he wants to go 94 right sorry
Queen D forward that was the idea hmm
that's it's absolutely true now I'm not
really no I'm not really doing all that
much hmm
do I have to trade Queens is threatening
made on a one basically so okay really
okay he's killing his own structure here
that is a bit surprising I mean not like
it's not lost or anything but it's not
helping to weaken yourself like that I
thought the position was quite equal now
I'm not so sure anymore maybe I'm a
little bit better
95 well if he takes so it's probably
equal if I take he will take with the
pond which is probably probably just
equality yeah this is also probably just
equality
I will seem I can still try a little bit
the way the pieces are positioned with
the book on e5 and the bishop on g5 he
has absolutely nothing else and just
sitting there I can go rook d5 but
actually this is not clear I can take
Bishop f4 and then he would have some
issues with the pawns okay okay it's
their way to enter with the King not not
so much okay I have to b5 I'm going to
take the a file so not so not minding
this much I should have I should have
brought the Bishop to e5 oh really
why is he doing that
keeping an eye on deform mmm he manages
a five for equality which is a shame the
skier for was bad I shouldn't have done
that
if I would have avoided that I think I
still would have had chances for a
slight edge not again nothing special
that's something where it would have
possible would have been possible to try
things yeah it's just it just equal
I can go there directly
I was you put I was a pretty unnecessary
oversight I've hidden I thought he would
go keen d5 of course a bit silly
hmm I totally forgot that I'm losing
this idiotic game oh my god this is one
of the most idiotic losses ever in
particular in particular because like
here this is this is really stupid he
played he played sorry the ridiculous
move Bishop takes t 3 but that turned
out to win I was just I mean it was
clear that you have to do this then keep
this take this next yeah and then yeah
stupid I mean I'm still drawing here it
seems if I like Bishop f6 remember there
were multiple ways to draw I can even
just take him and he cannot he cannot I
mean I also should never be in this
because I just had this nice position
the whole time and he and Frank Bishop
g7 1 yeah ok I didn't see why is the
problem so this this and e6 actually
wins but why
okay one thing I do understand this is
winning yeah that is a line that I do
understand but I didn't I couldn't quite
figure out here it quick f4 seems to win
a screen take g6 is impossible to stop
remarkable so that was a way to to win
the game iam okay well this is this is
bad yam but also I mean this ending
where only white can press them this is
just a super one-sided ending where I
can try forever and ever and ever and
this is really stupid this is a very bad
move king f4 I think I mean the engine
likes it but I should instead bring the
bishop 25 this is just better put the
bishop here and always keep an eye on
this now if he goes b5 this is a better
version of the game I think again it is
not much but why this is constantly
better and he I'm also just better I
mean losing is totally totally Wow so
yeah I mean by now it's equal now I've
managed to put it into an equal position
right okay I mean there were multiple
ways to draw at the end but the silliest
is really that I should never insure you
should never expect a move like this is
totally clear that this happens and
instead he played this when you just
take and you go home now no flight
Bishop d3 and I only expected this and
then I wanted to go here and yeah it's
just what what happened since but this
now I have to I have to find some stuff
which I did not manage so g5 was
terrible
they he's just in time to get the bishop
to
to to h5 it's really really a bad idea
it's really bad I mean you can do this
immediately er very I played like a
complete idiot yeah I mean this is
what's been so easy I don't know I was
too relaxed here it seems and this is
this is drawing now you just simply
eliminate all the points like this way
you get this at age 5 and you drawn oh
my that was said was giving away pawned
points for absolutely no reason
ok thanks for watching